hello less than a year after applying
for a NATO membership Finland is set to
become the newest member of the military
Alliance president Sally nanisto will
travel to Brussels for the ceremony
later on Tuesday finland's move away
from its historic position of
non-alignment follows Russia's invasion
of Ukraine Moscow has said it will
strengthen its military positions On the
Border in response
we will welcome Finland as the 31st
member of NATO
making Finland safer and our alliance
stronger
we will raise the Finnish flag
for the first time here at the NATO
headquarters
it will be a good day for Finland
security for Nordic Security and for
NATO as a whole
as a situation in Europe has changed
quite much over the last year uh I think
it gives Finland a new opportunity for
better safety in the future so we have
been for a long time we've been relying
on our independence and neutrality and
now we just realized that that's not the
path of the future now we need to look
for new options for the future in some
ways I think it will make Finland a
safer place but
we don't know what Russia will do and
like yeah it's all like a big question
for me I think so it's better than
nothing you know if they are alone
it's not
it's no chance in in this situation now
we are part of part of Western Europe
and this kind of bigger community so we
are we are part of this not not in a
liar so that brings the security to
implement
Let's cross over to Kiev and get more on
this with Jonah oh so Jonah it was the
war in Ukraine that really led to this
major change in NATO's makeup
yeah look in the simplest of terms uh
when Russia invaded Ukraine last
February it prompted a very significant
and Hasty rethink by countries bordering
Russia and close to Russia about their
security and about the extent of the
threat that Russia might pose to them
you may recall on the western side of
that thinking the smaller Baltic states
becoming extremely nervous at the time
but they of course were already NATO
members they benefited from the idea of
collective security via Article 5 the
idea that an attack on one is an attack
on all not so countries like Finland
with its 1300 kilometer plus border with
Russia and nearby Sweden that had long
held to a commitment of neutrality but
now with public support felt differently
so they applied at the NATO Summit last
May for membership it was very quickly
approved at a political level it had to
be approved by all NATO parliaments
unanimously finland's has been so it
goes through Sweden still pending
approval by key so what practical
difference if any at all will this
actually make to the war in Ukraine
I mean the reality is it's not going to
change the Dynamics of the war in
Ukraine right now it has important
strategic consequences I think for
Russia and for President Putin in terms
of his calculus about what he does next
and in the future there's already talk
about repositioning Russian nuclear
Assets in neighboring Belarus that is
likely a consequence of this vast
extension of NATO's border with Russia
uh the port of Saint Petersburg for
instance becomes the only bit of Black
Sea Coastline that isn't effectively
NATO controlled and for President Putin
himself and his goals in launching that
invasion of Ukraine one of them was
presumed to be of course containing and
undermining NATO preventing its further
Eastward expansion while NATO planners
will tell you today that he's achieved
exactly the opposite with this very
significant expansion of NATO taking in
Finland thank you so much Jonah Hall
reporting from keems